beta-lactam antibiotics antibiotics and
simply may define the type of substance
that affects bacteria in one way or
another one class of antibiotics there
is a beta lactam at about its function
by binding to a bacteria and suppressing
cell wall reproduction this results in a
reduction of cell wall synthesis which
leads as mosaic instability or autolysis
at cell death however due to the ovaries
the beta-lactam antibiotics new
bacterias have emerge that are able to
reproduce despite the presence of
antibiotics in addition there are many
modifications in these bacterias that
render the beta lactam practically
useless in some hosts we made this video
introduce to you the harms of the
overuse of antibiotics in the modern
world and this video will specifically
educate upon the topic of beta lactam
aces and resistance thick beta-lactam
antibiotics found in 1907 by a german
chemist named Hermann stood in here so
then again thrives about by stoner girls
showed to be a very effective way of
finding off bacteria compared to other
treatments during the time one reason
for the success of antibiotics include
the presence of the enzyme beta
lactamase this enzyme proved to be an
antibiotic resistance to the beta-lactam
antibiotics which includes that of
penicillin and others because of the
student success of these antibiotics
there are overused and have led to the
formation of several strains of
antibiotic resistant bacteria other
molecules have developed over time and
resistance to the beta lactam molecules
such as methicillin-resistant staph or
oast MRI se is among many bacteria that
have grown resistant to beta-lactam
antibiotics the resistance have limited
the effectiveness of beta lactam
molecules to a 2011 survey conducted by
the IDSA over 60% participants had seen
an untrue bacterial infections in the
prior year this could be related to the
overuse of gram positive beta lactam
this has caused an increase in
gram-negative bacteria resistant
Slatington upswing and deaths caused by
HIV and AIDS
another reason influenced by
gram-negative MRI say English in the
World Health Organization's these this
is the ends of the antibiotic era as
antibiotic resistance is causing much
harm this is all accurate towards the
overuse of antibiotics will further
drastically decrease the effects of
antibiotics and the increase in the
harms of gram-negative bacteria
you